In the last video we
established a reasonable
upper bound on the
1-year forward settlement
price of gold. We
established that at $1150
which is essentially
the sport price plus the
borrowing rate to borrow
$1000, plus the carrying
cost of the gold. What I
want to do in this video
is to think of a reasonable
lower bound. To do
that let's imagine a
world where instead of
the forward settlement
price being $1150, let's
imagine a world where the forward
settlement price is $1050.
It's still higher that the spot
price. Let's think of it from the
the point of view of
someone who wants to hold
gold in a year. Let's say
that you are that someone
and right now you have $1000
that you want to use to
give you gold. You want
to hold the gold for
the long term. You have 2 options here.
You could just buy gold
now. Buy 1 ounce with
your $1000 right now.
When you go forward a year
from then your going to
have that 1 once of gold
plus you're going have
to pay the carrying cost.
The safety deposit box and
the insurance on the gold.
You're going to have 1
ounce of gold minus $50.
That's what you're going have to pay.
The other option, you say
hey look instead of putting
my $1000 into gold right
now, let me put my $1000
into a risk-free bond.
Into a risk-free bond.
Risk-free bond, and at
the same time agree to
be the buyer on the
1-year forward settlement.
On the 1-year forward
contract. I'm agreed to
to be the buyer at $1050.
If you go forward a year,
your $1000 risk-free
bond is going to give
you 5% interest a year.
You're going to have
$1050. This is just the
interest on your bond.
Then you can use that
to go and buy the gold.
Which you all ready locked
in the price by agreeing
to be the buyer on the
forward contract. Then you buy the gold.
In both situations you end
up with an ounce of gold
a year from now starting with your $1000.
In this situation you
just have an ounce of gold
and you didn't have to
pay any carrying cost.
In this situation you
have the ounce of gold
and you did have to pay carrying cost.
So, clearly any rational
person, assuming their
buying the gold for the
long term, would want to do
this situation. They
save $50 over the course
of the year. Really, the
rational price, if this
were to happen everyone
would want to be the
buyers over here. We're
talking about $1050 price.
That's right over here.
This was the price in
the last example. Everyone
would want to be the
buyer on the futures contract
or the forward contract.
That would increase the price over there.
Knowing you'd have less
buyers on the spot contract.
That would decrease the price over there.
In general this price
seems too low. The price
at which people would
be neutral is if this
price was $50 higher.
Then it becomes completely
equivalent. A rational lower
bound given all of this,
would have been a price of $1100. $1100.
In general just going
back to the last video,
a ration upper bound
will be the spot price
plus the carrying cost
and the rate at which
someone could borrow money.
A rational lower bound
will be the spot price
plus the risk-free interest
rate and the carrying
cost. In general, the only
difference between those
upper and lower bound
is this rate and this rate.
This rate and this rate.
If these were the same the rational price
would be the same. If
these both were 10%, then
the rational price would
$1150. These were both
5% the rational price, the
upper and the lower bound
would have been $1100.